das wichtigste in diesem london ist zu
hause bleiben am liebsten auf der couch
und genau dafür wird jetzt im netz auch
werbung gemacht von der bundesregierung
mit verschiedenen clips heute morgen um
9 gab es den dritten den neuesten clip
stefan seibert hat ihn gepostet
dieses stück blech wurde mir damals
umgang im winter 2020 kurs von meinem 21
geburtstag ich wurde für meine
besonderen leistungen im kampf gegen
korona ausgezeichnet und plötzlich war
ich ein held
ein idol ein musterbürger zugetraut
hätte mir das niemand bevor krone
ausbrach war ich ohne zweifel die
faulste socke die jäh durch dieses land
geschlichen ist
ich habe meine wohnung sowie nie
verlassen sagte ohne ehrgeiz und pascal
de radio direkt aus der dose
wenn ich war zu faul sie mir warm zu
machen
eine freundin land nicht den faulen tobi
aber ich war auch zuvor ruhig darüber
aufzuregen als dann krone ausbrach blieb
ich der gleiche rolle sagt er ich vorher
auch gewesen bin
aber im gegensatz zu mir hatte sich die
welt verändert
[Musik]
um das virus einzudämmen forderte man
die leute auf zu hause zu bleiben
nichtstun war christian dienst an der
gemeinschaft
faulheit konnte leben halten
und darin war ich meister es waren
besondere zeiten damals hinter 2020
besondere schwere zeiten aber das war
leicht ein held zu sein
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bild schaut euch hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren